it is finally happening we are going to
get six years worth of Donald Trump's
tax returns after spending so much time
and so much money and so much effort
exhausting every possible means the
house Ways and Means Committee has the
tax returns and they have voted that
indeed they are going to release them
this is absolutely huge and we will talk
about what we might find in these tax
returns we already found out the
supposed audits that were taking place
we're not actually taking place we'll
delve into that in a moment Reuters
reporting U.S House committee to release
redacted Trump tax tax filings the U.S
House of Representatives committee voted
yesterday to release partially redacted
tax filings from Trump and said tax
authorities had failed to properly
scrutinize his returns while he was in
office despite endless breathless
apoplectic claims that the IRS is
working in a politically partisan way to
Target Republicans
Trump's filings were not even actually
scrutinized in the way he claimed that
they were the committee said the U.S
Internal Revenue Service did not follow
its own rules when it failed to audit
Trump's tax returns during three of his
four years in office
members said Congress should pass a law
to strengthen the presidential audit
program let's look at a video here of
Congressman Lloyd Doggett explaining
what we are going to get and when we are
going to get it that's going to be it
we're not also going to get all the tax
returns just to be very clear here you
will get all of the tax returns that the
Supreme Court and the lower courts said
that Mr Neal's request could get you
will get all of those that may be
delayed for a few days only to permit
through permit time to redact things
like Social Security numbers uh personal
ID numbers that type of thing but you
will get the complete uh Trump tax
returns such as they are
for the years that Mr Neal requested
okay so that's 2015 through 2020 just to
be clear yeah that's correct okay and I
think what uh I find surprising our
Focus had been on the IRS audit and
whether it was being done properly right
is the IRS did no audits at all
such time as the day they received Mr
Neal's request for these documents and
that day they requested the first audit
they have yet to complete a single audit
of Mr Trump can you imagine and we're
going to delve more into the audit part
but the critical question is at this
point in time what might we learn from
these tax returns amen a number of
different things Trump is not as wealthy
as he claims to be
almost certainly and in fact we have so
many other sources that suggest that is
the case we may learn about Trump's
conflicts of interest Trump's tax
returns could potentially reveal
conflicts between his business dealings
and his role as president of the United
States potentially conflicts of
interests uh with a national security
consequence and it could include details
about financial arrangements with
foreign governments or individuals or
questionable relationships we could
learn about tax evasion or outright
fraud there have been concerns for a
long time about Trump's Financial
dealings including weather and it seems
almost guaranteed that he is from
everything else we know whether he is uh
misstating
exaggerating or understating the value
of certain assets for whatever purpose
is convenient at the time use of
charitable funds Trump has been
criticized for his use of funds from
charitable found from the charitable
Foundation which remember had its own
legal problems some years ago including
that he was using that money as a sort
of personal expense slush fund in the
tax returns it's possible that we might
learn more about that hidden assets
whether Trump has hidden assets or
income streams that have not been
previously disclosed and there is much
more why would Trump work so hard to
prevent the release of the tax returns
well based on the reasons I just gave
you there could be legal concerns in
other words if indeed Trump's tax
returns contain information about
possible fraud or any of the other
things I mentioned that could
potentially be used against Trump in a
legal context it could be the evidence
for the of the tax evasion or fraud that
he has expected a suspected of engaging
in and that could be why he didn't want
the tax returns released image
protection Trump is extraordinarily Vain
and narcissistic the tax returns as I
mentioned might reveal Trump's not as
wealthy as he claims to be or that he is
debts that are maybe bad for his image
so image protection and thirdly to some
degree strategic considerations in the
sense that if he had normal followers
they might react to the information
contained in the tax returns negatively
and might abandon Trump doesn't have
normal followers we experience that
during 2016 and the phrase I could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and not lose any
support it actually seems much more
accurate than we might have assumed at
the beginning So in theory there would
be strategic considerations for Trump
wanting to prevent the release of his
tax returns in practice it's not clear
his followers really give to whatever's
uh about what the guy has done or
claimed or lied about or whatever the
case may be so we are days away maybe
even less
from the release of six years of Trump's
tax returns we will delve into it but
one thing we know the IRS audit claims
were lies I want to talk about that next
let's face it the holiday season can be
a stressful time for anyone even a
stressor on relationships in-laws
dividing time mismatched expectations
around gifts our sponsor paired is the
app that makes it easy to maintain a
feeling of connection with your partner
during this crazy time of year you and
your partner download the app you pair
together an everyday pair gives the two
of you questions or quizzes games to
have fun stay emotionally connected
deepen your conversations and all of the
exercises were developed by academic
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and paired
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversations and we can use paired on
the go don't let end of year stressors
get in the way of you and your partner
enjoying some connecting paired makes it
simple and giving your significant other
a paired subscription is a great last
minute holiday gift head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below